the most recent episode of Game of
Thrones that's the one everyone's
talking about it was an action-packed
episode but I don't know if you you know
been listening to what's going on a lot
of people are complaining that it was
poorly lit and too dark to see what was
going on during the battle scenes did
anybody else feel that way it was I mean
I that's how I felt I was watching it
was very hard because it takes place at
night in a snowstorm lots going on I was
still watching it going what is this
what's happening and well we actually
have here's a clip of the scene there
you go that's that was it you know what
I'm talking about and so credit I think
some critics have a point with that
issue well here's what I did I had our
editors brighten the footage come on we
have editors why do you
that's insulting that that would get a
laugh oh you have real people no we have
really good editors I had them brighten
the footage using state-of-the-art
technology the results were actually
less kind of surprising spoiler alert we
are about to see is a pivotal battle
scene from the last episode of Game of
Thrones with are technologically
improved lighting this is what it could
have looked like if he's real lighting
check it out
you